tomorrow marks one year since the deadly
riots on our nation's capital the
january 6 insurrection brought renewed
attention to the issue of extremism as
we mark the one-year anniversary since
what do we now know about the rise of
extremism in our country and the dangers
it still presents here to share more
with us is oren siegel vice president of
the center of extremism at the
anti-defamation league oren great to
speak with you and welcome to quick take
when we look back on the sixth about 21
of attendees had overties to right-wing
extremist groups but about 80 percent
didn't have any overties to those
organizations
since then have things gotten better or
worse among the american electorate
things have not gotten better right the
the narratives and disinformation that
animated people and brought them to the
capitol on january 6th in the first
place have not gone away in fact what
we've seen is whether it's the extremist
groups who are involved uh in the
capital like the proud boys or the oath
keepers or the majority of people who
are not card-carrying members of any
extremist group
continue to show up locally
at school board hearings we continue to
see threats
against medical professionals so again
the grievances that undermine our
democratic institutions are playing out
more locally throughout 2021
so so what do we do then right i mean
you mentioned that this is playing out
at the individual level in really strong
ways i mean i've noticed that in my
reporting on covid with parents going
back and forth about issues coming up at
school board meetings
what do we do to to move past the kind
of division that january 6th really
represented
you know it's a really tough question
because i think accountability is
important and seeing the over 700
arrests for those who are
involved in the insurrection is
important
but we also need a shared understanding
of what happened on that day and frankly
we're just not on the same page in this
country there are people who consider
those who are arrested to be political
prisoners right we have cable news
channels who are promoting additional
conspiracy theories about who is behind
those activities and locally i think
disinformation is continuing to animate
people because of vaccine mandates
school board hearings etc so i think
what is required is to get on the same
page
and then secondarily we need to train
people to be critical thinkers in terms
of the information that they're bringing
in especially on social media
well i i want to talk
exactly about that media consumption
question because 2021 saw a huge dip in
engagement with the news across
mainstream media outlets like fox cnn
msnbc was all down 36 overall with
viewership how does news consumption or
in this case a lack of it over the past
year play into this conversation
you know it sort of depends on what
people consider news i think what
someone sees on their facebook feed they
believe is news or if they view it on
you know some fringe platform as long as
somebody has an opinion or is trying to
promote an agenda i think people view
that as news and not understanding the
difference between what is actual news
and what is propaganda is one of the
issues here this is the environment that
enables disinformation to proliferate
and it's the environment that frankly as
a requirement for extremists to be able
to make inroads the more that there's
confusion the more that there's division
the more that there's polarization the
people who win are the extremists and
frankly i think so much of our political
discussion has become an extremist
discussion
yeah so i'm curious who if you could
kind of snap your fingers right now and
change one thing that's currently
fueling disinformation extremism what
would that thing be would it be language
from politicians would it be big tech
social media where would you start
i mean listen
all of the above i think fundamentally
though if
certainly we need people to consistently
and clearly call out uh conspiracy
theories and hate but i also think
social media companies need to do a much
better job
identifying how those platforms are
being exploited
and making sure that they're transparent
about what they're doing to try to
prevent that right it's not unreasonable
for users of these platforms to expect
that they will do more to protect the
safety of their users but also to make
sure that those narratives that animate
people to action and in some cases
violence
are not being amplified on those
platforms it's no longer unreasonable to
have that expectation
and a lot of experts believe that 2022
is the year we're finally going to see
some big regulation on big tech to what
extent do you think that would really
make an impact
on disinformation and extremism is
regulation and big tech enough or will
people just you know make new social
media platforms or find other methods of
communication if uh you know social
platforms were to get more heavily
regulated
i mean
there clearly needs to be both right so
there needs to be efforts um from our
policy makers
to carefully reform not eliminate but
reform section 230 of a law that
basically allows social media platforms
unprecedented immunity from legal
accountability we also though need to
recognize that the more that some of the
big name social media companies do
uh to [ __ ] down on on extremism that
extremists will find multiple other
platforms to migrate to right this is an
ecosystem but again
it's not necessarily a bad thing is as
they're migrating to different platforms
they don't have as huge of a bull horn
to express their hatred but those
smaller more fringe and upcoming
platforms need to make sure that part of
their development is to address
extremists before they overtake those
platforms as well
and i hear you mentioning the importance
of accountability orin the capitol
police chief testified today that
threats have significantly increased
over the past year testifying before the
senate rules committee and saying there
were over 9500 threats this year which
is an average of 26 per day the highest
number they've ever had i mean what
grade would you give the response to
january 6 particularly the january 6th
panel do you think that the response to
the capital siege was enough
listen i think a lot remains to be seen
right they're still in the process i
think again over 700 people arrested for
their role in the insurrection
is progress that is a level of
accountability i think frankly though
that what people ought to expect
is that
this should have been a wake-up call
right this should have been an
opportunity what happened on january 6th
to reject extremism and the and the
narratives that animate it
instead we have in many ways seen a more
full embrace
of these messages that undermine our
democratic institutions that normalize
the messages and the tactics that
brought these extremists and others to
the capital in the first place this is
from our social media this is from
elected officials this is from our cable
news channels
i mean the fact that we don't have a
shared understanding of how bad what
happened on january 6th is
is not a good sign yeah
why do you think it wasn't a wake-up
call why wasn't it a bigger shift after
the sixth then after i think a lot of
people thought that biden entering the
white house might also lead to a shift
because violence and extremism is
politicized in this country
right
i think every incident that occurs
whether it's a mass shooting whether
it's protests whether it's an
insurrection
you know eventually becomes part of the
political football
and unfortunately the people that are
lose that lose are not only just all the
american people but frankly our
democracy
right i had no idea 20 years ago when i
started to look into extremism and hate
that that work would end up being an
effort to push back
against extremism who are fighting for
the soul of our democracy against the
soul of our democracy and so this is
just part of the regular conversation is
that what used to be
language and narratives that i would see
on some french platform are now
literally the public discussions that
we're having and so the normalization of
hate and extremism the inability to even
recognize it and call it out
i think is is an epidemic
so help me define this who are the
biggest groups involved here who are the
biggest groups represented on january
6th then who are they targeting now
so in in terms of the the 20 or so
percent
of those who've been arrested on january
6th who were part of you know more
organized or established extremist
groups or movements we're talking about
proud boys oath keepers
um followers of q anon
and they haven't gone away in fact so
much of the activity that we've seen
throughout 2021 from the proud boys has
focused on attending school board
hearings right in opposition to critical
race theory or vaccine or mask mandates
right they've localized their approach
they're trying to win hearts and minds
in the local space they don't need to go
to dc anymore
and others too q anon for example that
hasn't gone away that conspiracy theory
as absurd that it is continues to bring
people out in the streets like in dallas
where people thought jfk jr was going to
come back right so the online spaces in
which most much of this propaganda
spreads and the ideas are sort of
incubated
we are seeing the activity on the ground
throughout the country the front line
against tate is not just our nation's
capital right it's in every local
community that we're in
i think that's a great place to leave it
oren thank you so much for joining us
really appreciate you breaking that down
and explaining uh the rise of extremism
since january 6 and that led up to it as
well thank you so much that was oren
siegel vice president of the center on
extremism at the anti-defamation league
you